Some familiar faces were missing...
...at a brand new shopping center in Moscow.
Western companies like McDonald's and Adidas...
...largely pulled out of Russia...
...after the conflict began in Ukraine.
But some locals at the newly opened Khovrino mall...
...claimed they were hardly missed.
Consumers were happy to buy, but not all stores were ready to sell.
Some companies faced what officials called...
...acute issues with logistics and deliveries.
One industry group claims Russian malls...
...have lost around 30% of footfall...
...since Western brands left.
Fried chicken chain KFC is one of the last to be seen.
Most of its Russian branches are independent franchises...
...over which parent company Yum Brands has little control.
Even so, officials from the new mall are positive about the future.
They believe 15,000 people per day...
...could visit once the center is fully operational.